Here's one of those.
A broken clock is right twice a day sort of
moments.
Brazen Fox News propagandist Sean Hannity
scolded Missouri partiers for not wearing
masks on Memorial Day and seemed to be defending
George Floyd, who was killed tragically by
police recently, a story that has gone viral.
Let's take a look at a couple of clips.
Here is Sean Hannity just seeming to make
sense on the topic of partiers massing together
on Memorial Day without wearing masks.
Take a look.
All right.
Lake of the Ozarks packed with party goers
this holiday weekend.
Look, I understand these are young people.
Experts keep saying over and over.
They're at a much lower risk.
But if they do get this and again, there's
no mass worry here that I see or not much
at all.
I see no social distancing.
But if they get the virus and then are in
contact with older and more vulnerable Americans,
that could be a disaster for others.
That's why in a short period of time, it's
only temporary.
You can't social distance, please wear the
mask.
Do it for your mom, your dad, your grandma,
your grandpa.
My humble advice.
You don't have to listen to me.
I'm not a doctor now.
I wish Hannity had said I'm not a doctor.
In his segment about hydroxy chloroquine a
few weeks ago, talking about a prophylactic
regimen of hydroxy chloroquine.
But he is right.
This is temporary.
We're all in it together.
If you're in a large crowd, if you're close
to people, just wear a mask.
Let's get through this together.
Help out your fellow humans.
Part of why it's so surprising that Hannity
is saying this is that he's been a locus of
misinformation and disinformation, propaganda
since the beginning of the Corona virus pandemic.
It's not just his hydroxy chloroquine cocktail
recipes that he gave out.
Hannity has been insisting that Trump had
the quickest and best response to the virus.
That's a laughable joke.
Hannity was arguing for a while that Corona
virus was less of a threat than the seasonal
flu.
Even in mid-March, Hannity was still citing
seasonal flu numbers as this completely meaningless
comparison to a novel coronavirus.
Now, at the same time, for a while, the same
people who are now saying wear a mask were
saying you don't need to wear a mask.
Now, I have to tell you, my position on this
has not changed.
I'm still skeptical of the need to wear a
mask outdoors when you're not near people.
If you're outdoors right on top of people,
if you're bunched together in a line for a
sustained period of time, if you were at an
outdoor concert, certainly the more we know
about the virus, the more we learn that the
spread is not really happening via surfaces
really as much as at once.
At one point was feared.
It's really person to person.
The more we learn that the vast majority is
happening indoors, the more we learn about
a certain amount of viral load needing to
be transferred from one person to another
for you to actually catch the disease, the
virus to be infected.
And often that requires 10 or 15 minutes around
someone not just passing them on the bike
path.
But it doesn't really matter.
It doesn't really matter.
You can look at European countries.
Just spoke to a Belgian friend who said people
aren't wearing masks outside in Belgium.
But still, Hannity is talking about people
behaving irresponsibly, partying in large
groups together with no masks.
And the real point is the disregard for the
lives of others.
And so, listen, the hypocrisy of Hannity does
not go ignored.
The utility of masks in reality has not actually
changed.
But if Sean Hannity is going to say this and
it might reach people in his audience, it's
a good thing.
One other Hannity example here is Hannity
yesterday actually going after the police.
In the George Floyd killing, saying, listen,
we're not doing, you know.
Trial by videotape.
But I don't understand what cops did here.
It doesn't make sense based on the video I've
seen and any opportunity for Sean Hannity
to brag about his martial arts practice.
He always takes advantage of.
Take a look.
And again, this is not trial by videotape
here.
That has nothing to do with it.
This guy's not resisting on any video we see.
You hear him clear clearly saying I can't
breathe.
Isn't how she'll imagine.
And I talked to my martial arts sensei trains
police officers for free.
He says it is scary to him how.
For most officers.
A lot of officers.
Their only option is what's on their their
sidearm.
That's it.
Or a stun gun.
They're not trained in the use of martial
arts.
But even if a rudimentary training would say
would, you would know how sensitive this is
to one's neck.
So very interesting sort of moments of clarity
on Sean Hannity's show.
Now, there's one other angle.
It's a very cynical angle, which is that Fox
News is increasingly afraid of getting sued.
And though and so they are starting to be
a little more cautious about what they say
regarding masks and social distancing and
the like, OK.
I don't get the sense that that's what's affecting
Sean Hannity's day to day coverage.
And lastly, remember, just because they say
one or two things, that makes sense.
These are not our allies.
These are people who profit from spreading
lethal disinformation for political gain,
allying themselves with the president and
carrying water for Donald Trump.
Their priorities are access to access access.
Rather said to elites and politicians and
profit.
Those are their priorities.
And, you know, when they say the right thing,
we'll take it.
It might save a life.
It might change the perspective of a Fox News
viewer.
Hey, you know what?
Maybe the police weren't justified in killing
or Clint killing George Floyd.
So we will take it.
But a future of critical thinking and empiricism
is not going to be catalyzed by Sean Hannity.
Even if he says wear a mask for grandma.
But to the extent that he can challenge the
echo chamber of anybody in the Fox News audience,
I'll take it and gladly.
So make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
We've got polls.
We've got behind the scenes pictures.
We have all sorts of stuff.
And on my Instagram at David Pakman, people
going crazy for my quarantine before and after
picture.
I did a split on my Instagram, what I looked
like two and a half months ago before the
start of quarantine and what I look like now.
It's been a slow change.
I barely recognize my own pre quarantine self.
Check it out on Instagram at David Pakman.
We will take a quick break.
We've got some very exciting stuff coming
up later today
on
the program.